i have an awful lot of questions i'm
just going to jump right on in um
uh
what was it like this is a this is a
curveball to start things off because i
had some people mention this on twitter
um what was it like for you when people
started talking about your star wars
nine script
was it weird for you was it like were
you reading what people were saying what
was it like we're going in hot huh oh
we're not [ __ ] i'm not messing around no
no no you're not um
gosh you know honestly i haven't thought
about how to answer that question um all
i'll say is is that
i am so um
grateful uh for the opportunity to have
told a story in that universe and i am
so proud of the story that we told uh
and
you know i i think that all of us as
fans
grow up having star wars stories in our
heads and things that we want to see on
screen and
uh everyone who's gotten the chance to
work on a star wars film for however
long
uh is given that gift uh i was given
some other gifts like you know i got to
hang out with mark hamill and you know
luke skywalker i got to meet george
lucas i mean these things are
i will carry with me for the rest of my
life
um and
you know
all of the work that we did uh on that
movie uh came from a very deep place uh
within me as someone who
uh you know considers it a bit of a
belief system if we're gonna be honest
and so
you know it's it's laid out for for for
all to see you know what's
what's within
people really loved your version the
people that have reviewed it online have
really loved your take on the material
was that gratifying
um you know what uh what i
i feel like talking too much about all
of it um
makes it seem not real it makes it seem
like something you know that we that
there's a bunch of people writing
scripts and and and making movies and
and i think there's a generation uh who
deserves to feel like this is as real as
we all felt it was
right i mean we you know you you send
your upc symbols in uh to get uh a boba
fett figure and that was that was at
that time the closest we could ever get
to it and now
i feel like you know we we learn so much
about what's going on behind the scenes
and and how these things are made that i
what i don't want to do is is take away
that magic that kids have of actually
believing this stuff happened a long
time ago very far away what do we need
to do as fans to get universal to make a
two-hour jurassic movie that just takes
place 65 million years ago and there's
just dinosaurs walking around and
enjoying life
well you know i i got to do that in this
movie and you know that's the beginning
of the film uh
and
for me
you know
there's just these couple you know
moments in in my life uh that i've been
able to
uh do something that i i never imagined
would be possible and in this case
having the absolute best animators on
the planet and a real location and the
resources to create uh the cretaceous
period in a way that feels you know i
think completely real i think the work
they did is just extraordinary uh it's a
highlight of my life of my career as you
can imagine uh so i can only look at it
you know in the context of that of of
just like this is dream realization
stuff uh for me yeah i want i'm not
joking when i say i want two hours of
that like i love that footage i i i
would watch two hours of that footage i
i think it you know there's and you know
favreau and did an amazing uh
documentary not to like advertise
somebody else's thing but it looks great
and i feel like you know this apple tv
piece that actually has attenborough
narrating it might satisfy that need
that all of us have to to see these
animals as they were so i will be
watching that i'm going to go ahead and
you know chill for somebody else's
dinosaur piece there have been a number
of jurassic park slash world movies um
and each one showcases what can go wrong
i do think it's just a matter of time
before someone on this planet creates
jurassic park for real how long do you
think before someone actually tries to
do this and it ends in disaster
well we don't know they haven't already
sure right we just don't know uh you
know the the incident jurassic park was
a secret for a long time uh so this
could have already all gone down uh i
think that
part of what we wanted to do with this
film was to illustrate
a bit more of a reality-based uh way
that wielding genetic power
irresponsibly can threaten the whole
planet uh
it is a sci-fi movie but it's not a
fantasy movie and so for us uh you know
finding a way to
acknowledge in us
in a way that you know if this really
happened if if dinosaurs were released
unto the world
how would that go down what would really
happen and i don't know that they would
be fighting each other you know in the
streets uh i think that it would
probably be hopefully a little bit more
like what we've shown and that uh you
know if you happen to encounter one uh
you know tread carefully this is the
closing chapter of this trilogy but
these movies are so financially
successful for universal that you know
at some point i don't know when they
will make another do you when they
eventually make another would you rather
them reboot everything and start again
or would you rather them continue in
this universe that has already been
existed this is just my own personal
opinion the one of the challenges of
this franchise is that to reboot it you
have to remake jurassic park
and i i weep for whoever takes that on
because that's that is one of the
greatest movies ever made and so i think
in a lot of ways we
our only choice is is to move forward
and to expand because
going back there and redoing uh you know
spielberg and creighton you know best of
luck yeah it's impossible it's it's it's
a it is a masterpiece straight up you
know um what dinosaur or dinosaurs ended
up coming the closest to being in the
film and why didn't they make the final
cut
ooh
there is a scene uh and if people have
seen the movie by the time we talk about
it uh when we're in the uh
uh the amber clave market the
underground market in malta uh there's a
scene where our list resource uh which
is the animal that ends up in the fight
ring with chris pratt sitting next to
kayla uh
has a fight with an oviraptor
uh and it's it's honestly one of my
favorite things in the movie uh and it's
not in the movie you'll get a chance to
see it someday uh but you know it's just
one of those those kind of moments that
is
you can kind of tell that you know it's
it's the 12 year old who was allowed to
make the film uh you know coming forward
and uh you know doing a sequence so
uh that one's pretty dope how did you
decide which dinosaurs would be
practical and which dinosaurs would be
cgi and like the mixture of both
um
that was actually a decision
uh
based on if if we couldn't make an
animatronic that would be the only
reason why we didn't do it
uh if an animal needed to move a certain
way if it was a certain size uh if
um it had to move at a certain speed uh
you know we would allow that to be
animated digitally if it was something
that a human had to interact with
tangibly we would always make an
animatronic uh or some kind of puppet uh
in this movie we
we had this third way that jay bayona
really pioneered uh that we just
fully embraced which is being able to
always have a fully realized painted
maquette uh even if it was animated
slightly that could be a lighting
reference to to make sure that the
digital creature looks flawless and uh
in this movie for the first time we're
able to have animatronics that have
digital extensions for appendages and
something that we didn't used to be able
to do in the past because the
animatronic and the digital like you
know just couldn't match the animatronic
always looked better uh but they're so
good now that there are a lot of shots
where you're looking at an animatronic
and then elements that have been
animated on it and i i know you can't
tell the difference it just it feels
seamless yeah you know what's
interesting if you re-watch uh real
steel that's what they did they built
those big robots and then animated parts
of it so you're mostly looking at
practical and it looks fantastic
i think what islam did on this movie is
is unbelievable
uh what was it like designing i believe
this is the first time there's like a
feathered dinosaur in one of these
movies um
yeah
am i wrong we have we have four of them
uh and
the one that uh really defined all the
others was the pyro raptor uh because we
made uh we made an animatronic for it as
a reference and we actually used it a
little bit uh and and the making of it
involved uh
all of these feathers to be gathered
from all around the world i would go in
and there would just be this table uh
full of you know 150 different kind of
feathers and they would you know hold up
four or five and like well which one of
these patterns do you like and you're
like okay uh and so layering all those
on top of each other and then seeing how
they react to wind and to snow into
water
uh
all of that was part of this really
really long development process that
resulted in what we did but
never did i stop being kind of shocked
that i get to stand next to you know
professionals on that level trying to
figure out what a feather dinosaur looks
like underwater uh who took home the
animatronic dinosaurs did you get to
keep one or is it just crazy expensive
and universal is like no
they they deteriorate after a period of
time because i actually wanted to use
the animatronic t-rex that we had built
for fallen kingdom in this
and it just they just don't they're not
able to hold up uh and so we talked this
time about finding ways to preserve them
like you might have to like put
something in a sealed uh box that is
never opened again which i think should
be on the table these things are amazing
pieces of film history i do get to often
keep you know i i don't like collect
props i often ask for like one thing uh
and on this movie i asked for um
the the juvenile baryonyx that's in the
movie is missing an arm but has a
a prosthetic arm with with different
claws and stuff on it and i got the
prosthetic arm
on twitter i put i was going to talk to
you and there was a lot of questions on
twitter one of the ones that kept
getting repeated was how would you rank
the power of like the bigger dinosaurs
like who do you think is the most
powerful can you sort of rank the power
of the largest dinosaurs and what you
think
oh
um
well i think the story has told us uh
that the spinosaurus is probably the
most powerful that's the t-rex killer um
i think in you know in this film uh we
see that the giganotosaurus
in a lot of ways is is you know able to
best the t-rex you know in
multiple periods multiple eras
um and uh
to me i think
you know if i'm really gonna i feel like
i'm just playing right into uh you know
somebody winning or losing a bet
um
so i'm gonna cost somebody some money uh
i to me like you know i know
the spinosaurus and the giganotosaurus
and the t-rex you know are all apex
predators uh of their era and and and of
their area if we were able to see all
three of them fights
um
well
you know then
someone will make some money off of that
fight i want to read this question to
you it's another off twitter uh can you
confirm if the spinosaurus in camp
cretaceous is the same spinosaurus as in
jurassic park three
my instinct is actually no because it
sounds different but i'm a nerd so what
i don't want to do is mess it up for
everyone making camp cretaceous i'm
going to screw this up for them i found
it to be a slightly different animal
like you know on-site and on sound um
but man like these are the kind of
things that i can really you know i'm
not believe it or not i'm actually not
the authority on everything uh and so
sometimes uh
it's kind of what you want to believe
is that all right
you know
no no
i think letting your imagination the
amount your imagination's always going
to be the most powerful thing
i don't i just like i don't want to
dictate it to everybody because it's
part of the joy of being a fan
sure um what would have happened if the
original cast had said no
oh
well that i mean
i don't know i guess it might have hurt
my feelings
i'm a very
actually just a very sensitive guy who's
you know i i wanted them to to want to
come back and i wanted them to trust me
uh which was the most important thing
that you know i'm not steven spielberg i
will never be steven spielberg and the
last time you know laura dern uh had a
lead in one of these movies he was
directing her and so to to to ask her to
come back and trust that i'm going to uh
honor this character to respect this
character uh to listen to her and and
work with her to make sure that the
ellie sattler of 2022 feels like a
natural progression and the same person
as the one from 1993.
that was the trust that had to be built
and with each of them uh individually
and as a group um but look i mean i i
don't feel like i can ever be
an authority on any of those characters
the actors who played them are are the
authorities so for me uh i just listened
and we collaborated and i think the
result is something that uh it comes
from all of us it's not just for me
what was it like behind the scenes so
you had you guys decided okay let's go
after the original cast and then we're
to write the script or rewriting the
script and then going after the original
cast like what was that dynamic like it
was a little more fluid and that we had
had
you know i had worked with jeff obama a
little bit and then i sat down with
laura and i sat down with sam and they
were all aware uh and so there's all you
know there's the hollywood deal making
of it all but then there's also this
look each other in the eye and say
listen if if i can do something that
feels worthy will you come and join us
and and i had that you know from each of
them and then at that point it was a
process of emily and i you know really
digging in and having conversations with
each of them about what we were doing
ever you know we don't hide our scripts
uh everyone who's in our movies knows
exactly what happens in every scene uh
and i think that's important because
ultimately when you watch this movie
i hope that when you get to the end
you'll feel that each of the characters
have been honored the new ones the
legacy ones all of them
and that came from us doing it together
partially because we were all living in
a hotel together
and we're hanging out on weekends but it
was also you know the same philosophy
that i i applied to my first films a
smaller film safety net guarantee was a
similar kind of setup but we were just
in there doing it together so
the filmmaking on this uh certainly not
in scope or scale or cost but in process
was closer to safety not guaranteed than
anything that i've done since then if
you could go back in time to
to the days you were filming jurassic
world would you have added anything to
that movie that would have helped you
with the sequels in terms of paying off
something or do you know what i mean
because when you were making that you
didn't know ultimately where two and
three were gonna go
no actually if i i don't have a specific
but i would probably say that more about
uh fallen kingdom uh and and this movie
and that you know
that was a movie that you know we built
and then i really gave it to another
filmmaker who i respected to put his own
stamp on it and i wanted to honor that
relationship and my respect for a fellow
filmmaker and so the process of ja
making the movie you know resulted in a
film that then i needed to
to go in and and
make sure that if you watch all three of
these movies in a row they're gonna feel
like one long story even though i was
making some adjustments for some of of
his creative instincts which i was super
down with and i and i thought were
awesome uh and so in the end you know if
you're if you're able to pivot a little
bit and you're able to
to make sure that you're you're not
ignoring choices but but following them
to their logical conclusion hopefully we
end up with something that you know if a
kid born today sits down and watches all
these movies in a row which i know is
going to happen they'll feel like they
saw you know one long narrative did you
have any alt titles besides jurassic
world dominion or was it always that
was that was the first one that
kind of stuck i had this create like
when i first
came like i wanted to change the title
each time which we in retrospect was
probably crazy because you know it's you
know we live in a society but i i wanted
to say it was like jurassic
world jurassic earth jurassic kingdom
like i just kept changing it uh and i
think part of it's because like i want
to make original movies so i just don't
want them to you know i wanted to feel
like they're each their you know
standalone event um
and
you know perfectly happy with the way it
turned out and i know that you know i
already changed the name of this
franchise once so i probably gotta like
chill on that how did it work actually
because one of these things one of the
things about this movie is that you have
to balance telling your story
getting all these cast members to get
along you got to make the studio happy
and let's be honest like these movies
sell a lot of merchandise so you have to
like universal merchandise or consumer
products is probably weighing in a
little bit in terms of some of the stuff
what is it like behind the scenes trying
to balance all of that and also make the
best movie you can make honestly the
the toys part is the easy part and
that's because i love it yeah i really
get into making sure that we have you
know
everything that mattel needs to for kids
to be able to go off and continue to
tell stories to themselves uh away from
the screen uh is something that matters
to me and so hopefully you know people
who collect toys and also kids who play
with them all recognize how much
time and effort and care we put into
to the toys we're making uh easy uh
making a great movie is what's hard and
making a movie that uh is to serve the
needs of of multiple generations and
recognizing that there are some things
that i'm going to do to serve uh the
generation that grew up on jurassic
world
that might bump a bit for jurassic park
fans and vice versa um i think i've
learned a lot you know over the years uh
and
hopefully this is a movie that you know
you can't satisfy everyone uh but can
can make everybody feel like they've
been heard and that you know i'm telling
a story for them too um but you're right
you know it's it's uh it's something
that
it's almost impossible to do it alone so
having that input from everyone else can
sometimes be helpful because everyone's
an individual everyone has a different
perspective and in the end like you know
this is a billion people who are going
to have a perspective on this movie over
in its lifetime uh unless you know
nobody sees it but i think people are
going to go
yeah i'm confident people at least five
people are going to see that please come
show up to our movie
when people are watching the movie are
there any easter eggs or moments that
maybe they should pay attention to on
screen well i trust uh our
innate understanding of every single
second of jurassic park for people to be
able to spot the easter eggs on their
own
i try not to i didn't i try not to do it
there's not a lot of like intentional
nostalgia in this movie because i know
it's naturally going to happen anyway
like it's it's in my blood and so you
almost can't help yourself uh and so i
just trusted you know except for one or
two things which you know you can't
really miss uh that just by the nature
of of being a jurassic park fan this
thing is just gonna you know be woven uh
with references so if anything i try to
push back against it
yeah
is one of the references a hat
yeah
sure
yeah
i think people might see it um so as you
know i love talking about the editing
process because it's where it all comes
together so um did you have a much
longer cut of the movie like how did you
like did you have an assembly cut that
was like three something hours you know
how did that all work we didn't ever
have an assembly cut uh that was three i
actually
i don't watch the assembly
uh i just go in uh and we just i work on
it in reels so i'll just watch the first
reel and we'll we'll work on that
together and then the second reel i feel
like the movie has to
i have to earn the movie's ability to be
watched
like
in it's in its entirety uh and so
in that process you know our our first
cut together my editor and i uh mark
sanger uh it's it's a little more
streamlined and kind of closer to where
we're going to end up um
there's a there's i would say about 14
minutes of footage that isn't in the
theatrical release uh that uh
uh people will very likely have a chance
to see someday uh but also at the same
time it is already a long movie you know
we're two hours and 26 minutes and it's
already 20 minutes longer than any other
jurassic movie has ever been so we had
to find a balance uh when it comes to
bringing people out to the theater after
all of this time that they haven't been
out to the feeder
and hopefully you know
these versions will be able to live on
in ways that if you're really interested
in going deeper into it we're going to
give you that opportunity and if you
love the movie that we're about to
release then you'll always have that too
uh what was the last thing that you cut
out of the film before you picture
locked and why
well i know what it is
um
and i would like to know what it is too
there is a scene uh
between ramsay cole mamadou's character
uh and
campbell scott you know louis dodson uh
there's no dinosaurs in it uh it's just
a piece of performance uh and it's these
uh two actors uh you know someone who's
playing you know
uh someone who had great trust for this
man who feels betrayed by him uh and a
man who's revealing a side of himself
that
this younger man has never seen before
uh and it also does a lot to to
go further into understanding uh
the intentions of biosin uh when it
comes to this ecological disaster that's
been created all around the world the
mistakes that were made and why this
character actually uh only cares to
cover up his mistakes and move on uh i
love those two actors so much so this is
just more me as a director than a
dinosaur fan uh but that was that was
kind of the last thing uh and i know
people will get a chance to see it but
every little bit hurts uh every little
bit hurts
was it like a minute or two or was it a
longer scene than that no it's probably
like a two and a half minutes it's a
good good little chunk of movie
um you know and it's just one of those
i'm sure every and this isn't you know
there's no
you know studio gun to my head it's it's
not one of those scenarios it's where we
just we just recognize like look this
this needs to be streamlined in a
certain way uh in order to make sure
that people who want you know the
the richer uh you know more
hopefully hopefully more fulfilling
experience but what do i know i think
oftentimes movies can feel a little long
so i think it's you know it's it's
something that everyone's gonna have
their own opinion on i think the movie
we have
uh
moves in a way that doesn't feel like
it's you know a two hour and twenty
minute movie uh and that's what's most
important it's it's not the length of
the movie uh it's the experience you
have while watching it and the pace of
it while you watch it i'm very proud of
the movie uh and yet i'm also really
excited that you know that we have more
stuff to share with people well the
thing is like you have a lot of main
characters if this movie was an hour and
50 minutes i think a lot of people would
feel shortchanged because that means
it's only so many scenes with each of
these people yeah every character needed
to have a beginning middle and an end
and that really was you know if anything
like
things that went away might have been
you know the character had two middles
uh and so
in that process
uh i believe that when i get to the end
of watching this movie i can look at
each of the characters there's a point
where they're all lined up next to each
other and i can look at all of them and
i know why each of them was absolutely
necessary in order for the story to
reach its conclusion and
that's the challenge especially when you
have you know nine people uh who all
deserve uh to be honored and respected
uh did you guys debate having a post
credit scene
no um yeah i mean look i i think
post-credit scenes are very much the
prevalence of marvel and they're they're
pretty exciting whenever they happen
it's the promise of the future uh which
is is
uh
almost part of the experience now with
those movies and they you know they
excite me as well and uh but it's you
know it's never really been uh something
that that we've done and you know we're
different we make a movie every three to
four years and uh it's
i hope that you know one of the things
that'll bring people out to the theater
is that they haven't seen jurassic in a
really long time and uh
that it'll feel like a new kind of
experience and that's it's all we can do
another question from twitter uh as this
trilogy closes do you think iceland i
i'm gonna butcher the name isla sorna
might be something that gets explored in
a future movie well i can't say no uh we
do we do mention it in this movie as
you'll see and we understand a little
bit more about um
where some of the dinosaurs uh went um
but yeah i i don't know if i can comment
to that at this point i would never say
no to anything because
look like i i was given an extraordinary
opportunity to be the custodian of this
uh for the past seven or eight years i
think there is another young filmmaker
out there who deserves that opportunity
as well uh so you know if anything i i
wouldn't want to tell them what it's
going to be they should tell us what
it's going to be uh one of the things
that this movie does is it has an action
set piece that is not on an island or in
you know not on the island or in the
theme park if you will it's in malta it
is outside in the real world uh can you
sort of talk about crafting something
like that and what you were looking to
accomplish with that action set piece
you know there are a lot of different
moments of dinosaurs in our world in
this movie uh and yet to me that one
uh
it's where our filmmaking language
changes in the franchise a little bit
you know stephen uh spielberg who who
made this extraordinary film with a very
specific
kind of of grace to the way the camera
moves uh the way that he shoots is
something that all of us to a certain
extent have emulated or
or you know created films that can stand
alongside that as best they can
multi we we have a handheld sequence and
we have something that feels like our
you know
if there's a guy on the on the back of a
vehicle that he's just trying to capture
these dinosaurs uh and he just captured
a piece of them so
to me being able to to go a little bit
more down and dirty with it uh and to
shake that up a bit uh it was exciting
and hopefully something people embrace
uh and
you know
again yeah i'm just like i hope you like
it you know sometimes when you're making
a movie and you want to film in a
location or you want to do something
often you know people might say no is it
easier for people to say yes when you
say yeah but it's a jurassic world movie
oh yeah for sure um yeah malta uh well
one of the reasons
um
why we got to
shoot in malta so extensively is that
we're the first movie to ever actually
shoot malta for malta
uh in modern day and just say you know
this is this is a city this is what it
is and uh they were thrilled about that
so they gave us a tremendous amount of
support and i actually got to go back um
and uh
uh
see a bunch of uh people who care about
malta very much watch the malta sequence
uh
maybe it was on my laptop and i
shouldn't have done it and like i
shouldn't say it out loud but it's
possible uh that some of the people we
worked with not just like people people
uh you know walking on the street uh but
some of the people we worked with got to
see it and it was amazing for them to
like they see every single landmark and
they're so proud of of their city and
how it's featured in this movie so
i now like by proxy have a little
hometown pride for malta uh you worked
with michael g aquino on all uh on all
these jurassic world movies um what is
it actually like hearing his music for
the first time when he like how does it
work does he send it to you are you in
the room like and what is it like
hearing that music for the first time
because he's what we call real good
he's real good um
what's interesting is that the first
time you hear it you know it's more it's
like a midi right you're not you're not
hearing the orchestra play it and you're
i'm with him and you know he's seen the
movie and then he goes through and he
creates a set of themes and i usually
just listen to the themes first and then
he shows me you know
how he's woven them into different
sequences but there's
it never feels the way that it does when
the orchestra plays it and so there's
always this this two-tiered level of
astonishment from probably any filmmaker
i only speak for myself but it's hearing
the themes and feeling like yep that's
that's the intention that's what we're
all trying to do and oh that surprised
me i didn't think of it like that but
yes let's definitely do that
and then you're at abbey road and they
play it
and you're like oh my god i can't
believe i get to be here you got to be
there i remember
uh
it was right it's it's
it's it's absolutely uh just one of the
coolest experiences uh and in this case
uh that orchestra hadn't played together
for a long time it was coven and they
all got to come back together and play
their instruments as a group
for the first time in you know at least
you know a year and it was very
emotional for all of them to do that so
eve and i was there and michael was
remote you know in in california so we
you know we're all still wearing our
masks and we had to do it that way but
um it was it was very emotional for that
reason it was we we all felt like oh we
might you know make it through this on
that note sir i'm going to say
congratulations
um i wish you nothing but the best and
good luck with all the other interviews
you're doing over the next few days
thank you
you